it's Christmas already overdue doctor
who reviewed time and yep
I have already arrived at the next
Christmas special and as has often been
the case I am on the record as not being
an exceptionally big fan of the
Christmas specials I don't like the the
pantomime ich worki tone that they just
feel they they either feel that they're
obligated to do or they feel like they
can get away with it and I just don't
like it and there aren't a ton of these
that I enjoy especially and we have
arrived at one of the more notorious
ones certainly tends to get lower
rankings both among the episodes written
by Steven Moffat in addition to the
Christmas specials in general the doctor
the widow and the Wardrobe I had fun
watching this that's not the same as me
saying it's good we'll get to that but I
enjoyed watching this I actually live
tweeted my thoughts on it which is the
first for me I think I'm gonna start
doing that when I get to my rewatch is
for overdue Doctor Who reviews so keep
an eye on the Twitter but I I did find
enjoyment and actually I found more good
things in it that I remember there being
coz to my memory
the only good thing and it was mad
because I think match is great I love
her vibe and her feel in her rapport
with the doctor I really love that she
basically flips on mom mode and just
tells him off at the end to send him up
to Amy and Rory to be a good friend
instead of letting them think he's dead
oh I love Matt she's great I love that
she you know cries to get these people
to stop pointing guns at her but she
was packing heat the entire time I
really do enjoy her I think she's got a
great presence now like you said my
memory was that she was basically the
only good thing in the episode that's
not really true there are some other
good bits here and there some good
moments and but it is mostly that the
good stuff comes in small bursts little
bits like there was a line from the
doctor that is a brilliant line because
he taught he's talking to Madge about
because he knows that her husband's end
that she hasn't told the kids yet and
she doesn't want to because that will
make Christmas for her kids forever will
be when they found out their dad died so
she's holding off on that and the doctor
says to her you find yourself wondering
what's the point of them being happy now
if they're going to be sad later and the
answer is of course because they're
going to be sad later which is a great
line it's a great line it's honestly a
good just general piece of guidance and
advice that was props to you Moffat you
nailed it with that one and I do get
enjoyment out of the fact that the
doctors finally confronted with
basically a wooden alien so the sonic is
useless I like that he actually turns to
the turns to the sonic can goes this was
always gonna happen you know so I get a
kick out of that um I don't even mind
the cheesy ending like it's Christmas
I'll let that fly that might seem odd
coming from me given that I tend to
complain about the oh dude did they just
go it's Christmas we can do whatever and
my issue is I'll accept that in the
ending as a way to get us a happy ending
from a story that might otherwise have
ended not quite so happily under other
circumstances but when you take that
vibe you spread it across the entire
episode yeah then I'm not super thrilled
about that and that's what I tend to see
in episodes like Christmas invasion
which
yeah boy I really really don't like that
thing but anyway anyways I roll with the
vibe I dig mad but there isn't a ton
else going on here
the premise is very loosey-goosey it's
it's meandering it's kind of fairytale
esque which is a vibe I can usually go
with okay I don't know it doesn't it
feels like an ill-fitting vibe for
Doctor Who a fair amount of the time at
least in terms of the execution when it
actually comes down to it I that said I
do actually like the idea of there
basically being a planet somewhere out
there with Christmas check decorations
as naturally occurring phenomenon I love
that idea that is a very Douglas Adams's
esque idea so that that's that works for
me
other than that though you know the kids
are okay the younger kid ceral yeah he
is he's not particularly good and it is
exacerbated by the glasses that they
have him is who's got these huge owl
eyes every shot that he's in and it just
it looks awful and he's not a
particularly good actor the sisters not
bad
she works decently enough the the three
bumbling idiots on the on the planet
that Madge disarms that they weren't bad
but they kind of extended their sort of
Three Stooges - the slapstick routine a
bit longer than I think it should have
been like it's fine it's a funky
situation they're pointing their guns at
a woman but then they're also kind of
arguing about it like that's a funny
enough situation but like execution-wise
they needed
speed that up they lingered on that
whole thing for way too long and it just
went on for a while without changing or
evolving the joke in any way so you know
that didn't work especially well the
whole sua's of this thing are patently
ridiculous because she secured the whole
forest in her head I'm sorry what um
that said like she performs really well
you know she goes into this kind of Zen
thing which I kind of dig but uh the
mothership the doctor being like oh well
it's gotta be her cuz it's the
mothership cuz she's a mother's like
that actually wasn't a bad idea like
connections wise for the show but like
the fact that it seemed so proud of
itself for that mm-hmm
yeah no no no nobody needs that the the
wooden aliens also don't look great I
know it's a tough time when you usually
working in foam you need to make
something that looks like a different
kind of material that can be tricky if
it needs to move all the trickier so
like I I get the limitations of it I
still don't really think those those
outfits look particularly good though
sorry I don't I'm not sure I have a ton
more to say like it's not worth
recounting the plot on this one the I
think another thing it just kind of
annoys me is the connections to the
lines of which in the wardrobe are
incredibly tenuous the doctor calls the
TARDIS's wardrobe I guess to round out
the the whole thing except we already
had a wardrobe surrogate with the
Christmas box that is also a portal to
another planet so like hey
I don't even know Maja's great I love
Matt Matt Smith money isn't being overly
goofy I think they dialed up the
child-like on him a bit high especially
in the front end when he's first meeting
the kids and like I get why but I still
find it grating like I can understand
that why the decision to do something
was made and still not enjoy it all
right so that is the doctor the widow
and the Wardrobe
Yuri watched it lately probably not it's
not the it's not the season for that but
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it you can also support me on
patreon where you get access to select
videos including all overdue doctor who
review early and before anyone on
YouTube is able to see them in addition
to that of course there's the usual like
subscribe yada yada yada links for a
bunch of stuff is down in the
description and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]